PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AGUIAR-CURRY AND WE ARE
VERY CLEAR WALDRON WANT TO
HEAR BLOOM MOSTLY HERE BLOOM
HERE CABALLERO GABRIEL BUT
I GRAYSON HERE LACKEY YES
MA'AM LACKEY HERE RE-ATTEMPT
OKAY I WELCOME
AGAIN TO START WITH A.
B.
TEAM SEVENTY SEVEN SOME
REMEMBER GIPSON THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT GO ALONG WITH
IT ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN WHICH
WILL HELP PROVIDE RESIDENT
BEING SERVICED BY THE SINGLE
LARGEST -- THERE IS A THERE'S
CURRENTLY A WATER CRISIS IN
DISTRICT RESIDENTS ARE BEING
-- SURVIVING TEEN DOT COM
ARE EXPERIENCING BAD WATER --
THANK YOU I WILL NOT TOLERATE
THIS INCLUDES BROWN WATER
COMING FROM THEIR FAWCETT FAST
SO PROTOTYPES FOR MAINTAINED
INFRASTRUCTURE AGING WELL
THE TEAM A LACK OF FINANCIAL
RESOURCES AND TECHNICAL
EXPERIENCE ON TO ADDRESS THESE
CHALLENGES THIS BILL WOULD
THEREFORE REQUIRED THE STATE
WATER BOARD TO ORDERS TO TO TO
TO ACCEPT ADMINISTRATIVE AND
MANAGERIAL I'M SERVICES ROBIN
APPOINTED ADMINISTRATOR THIS
WHO WILL ENSURE THE CSU TEAM
UP TO HAVE EXPERTS NEEDED TO
ADDRESS ARMED FOR WATER QUALITY
FONDREN FIFTH ARE STRICTLY HAVE
TO LIVE UP TO DEVELOP WE HAVE
MANY -- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
KEEP ONE FINGER OVER COUNTY
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ANYONE ELSE SUPPORT THEIR
WITNESSES OF IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE -- ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE RANMA MOTION
PROJECT CLOSE THREATEN THEM
AYE VOTE OKAY AND THAT SECTOR
CALL THE ROLL AGUIAR-CURRY HI
EVER CARRY AYE WALDRON WALDRON
AYE BLOOM TIME MIGHT HAVE A
HERO I'VE COME HERE I KEEP
RAIL FOOD GABRIEL AYE GRAYSON
AYE GRAYSON AYE LACKEY FIVE
LACKEY AYE REASONS EVEN SIZE
VOEPEL ISNT FILLS OUT NINE
ZERO THANK YOU VERY LEADS
US IN A MEMBER MCCARTY AND
EIGHT MILLION SEVEN ZERO NINE
RIGHT WELCOME THANK YOU
THANKS FOR OUR WORKING WITH
IT THE LAST FEW WEEKS THIS
IS A DISTRICT IN OVERLAKE
YOU ARE REGIONAL TRANSIT AS
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM IN
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY AREA
HAS GREATLY QUESTION YOU MINOR
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS TO THE
GOVERNING STRUCTURE FIVE ONE
MAJOR WHAT SIGNIFICANT ONES
WHICH WILL ALLOW THEM TO
PLAY SALES TAX MEASURE ON THE
BALLOT YOU COMMIT ONE EIGHT
CENTS PERSONS ONE QUARTER
PERCENT -- THIS IS OF COURSE
OUR OUR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
IF YOU SEE HER TWENTY MILLION
PASSENGERS ACROSS THE AREA
YOU'LL PLEASE HELP MAKE THE
SYSTEM WORK QUIETLY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF IT WITNESSES
WILL SUPPORT HIGH MARC WATTS
REVERSING SECOND PROGRAM
TRADERS I THINK ANY OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE SEEING NONE OF
THE WITNESS THOSE IN OPPOSITION
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS INSTANCE
THEY BACK HERE IT WILL HURT
YOUR HERE'S IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL WE UNDERSTAND EXACTLY
FROM TRAINS IT DOES HAVE TO --
THROUGH AUTHORIZED SALES TAX
AND THERE IS RUMOR THAT RILEY
BRINGS YOU BRING THEM TO YOU
ISSUES BUT WE SHOULD MAKE THE
LOCAL AGENCY PASS SUCH CASH
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE YEAH I KNEW
THAT HE HAD WORN EGGMAN EASIER
FOR THEM TO PROGRESSIVE SALES
I THINK ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE WELL WE HAVE
A MOTION AND EMOTION SECOND
THE MOTION A MONTH AGO
OKAY SO -- COMEY ARROW AND
OKAY WHICH I TO CLOSE AS
HERE I DON'T THINK YOU EVER
WELCOME SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL ACTION IS THAT CONCURRENT
SENATE AMENDMENTS AGUIAR-CURRY
MINE AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON
WALDRON NO BLOOM FACT LOW
AYE COVER EURO CABALLERO AYE
GABRIEL GABRIEL I GRAYSON
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY LACKING
NO RE THIS REVERSE AYE VOEPEL
NO VOEPEL NO SO SUNSET FILLS
US SIXTY THINK VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOVE FRIENDS SO JONES
SAWYER AND THIS IS ON AB
TWELVE ZERO FIVE WELCOME
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I WANT
TO FIRST THANK YOU CHAIR A
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE TWENTY MINUTES
WHICH I TO LEAD MAKE BILLS
LOCK AB TWELVE FIVE WOULD
IMPROVE THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN AUTHORITY ABILITY
TO CONTRACT WITH SMALL BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES WILL ALSO CREATE
AND A MEDIUM BUSINESS SET ASIDE
TO ESTABLISH A GROWTH PATH FOR
SMALL BUSINESS PARTNER MAKE
SURE SURE TRANSPARENCY AND
AND AND ESTABLISH SAFEGUARDS
IN THE PROCUREMENT PROCESS
THE FOLLOWING AMENDMENTS TO
TAKE BOTH PROGRAM ABOUT ONE
PERCENT SAID THEY FOR SMALL
AND MEDIUM BUSINESS PROGRAMS
TO REPORTERS HARM TO SHOW
THE ONGOING PROGRESS OF THE
PROGRAM PILOT LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF CONTRAST ONE HUNDRED
AND MEADOW BUSINESS SET ASIDE
PROGRAM I FINALLY SPECIFYING
THE DEFINITION OF MEDIUM SIZE
BUSINESSES WITH ME TODAY ANDREW
AND PRE COPY HALF OF LA METRO
SPONSORED THE PILLARS FOR YOU
I WAS -- SUPPORT WHICH I THINK
THE SPECIFIC OR NOT VERIFIED
LEARNING HOW INNOCENT
OPPOSITION SAYING THAT --
WE HAVE -- ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE I'M A MOTION
AND A SECOND -- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE PERFECT FOR A
VOTE -- SECRETARY HUMBOLDT
ANDROGYNOUS TO CONCURRENT
SENATE AMENDMENTS AGUIAR-CURRY
HI AGUIAR-CURRY AYE WALDRON
WALDRON I NOTICED THAT LOW
HI
REALLY MY REAL AYE GRAYSON
THIS THIS LAKE
OUT NINE ZERO AND I I'M NEVER
GOING TO GIVE IT A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE FOR THIS LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE DE FACTO